we don't like the phrase work life
balance and i want to see the reaction
and the truth is not because and you'll
see us in the second the the last value
it's the reason is we're actually not
looking for people that want this
balance but rather the people that
think that the this job will be a
significant part of their life not
there's no balance between job and life
because we want you to feel that this
job is an important and meaningful part
of your life
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
i am very excited for this episode meet
michael brakestone the co-founder and
ceo of noralite.ai
mikha is a repeat entrepreneur who's
founded a few great businesses example
chorus ai acquired for 575 million
dollars by zoom info and a few less
successful ones he's currently the
co-founder and ceo of neuralight.ai a
venture-backed startup on a mission to
transform the lives of more than a
billion people suffering from
neurological disorders by digitizing
neurological insights and care adventure
he hopes becomes his magnum opus
mija breakstone welcome to 20 minute
leaders i'm so incredibly honored to
have you here let's talk about impact
and entrepreneurship how are you
i'm doing uh well uh you said to be
authentic so i'm very very tired i just
woke up five minutes ago or so so that's
also why i how i look uh you also said
this can be redacted so uh
um you don't no need to do that i'm
doing really well very tired
entrepreneurs uh unfortunately sometimes
have to work harder than they want to
although i'm trying to get back in the
regime of at least six hours a night but
i'm i'm excited i'm really really happy
to be doing this with you
um i've i've you know read uh and and
seen the other episodes you did i think
even the choice of this uh 20 minutes
leaders and not entrepreneurs or
co-founders or whatever i think it's
such a beautiful name and it really
represents also
a lot of why i chose to be an
entrepreneur so
uh very short questions i love it long
answer excited
i i'm you know i think that you really
embody you know what i look for here
michael because
um
you're coming in here i'm waking you up
very early time for you and austin and
relocating in order to to build your
your next company you've
you've helped build as a co-founder and
cto chorus ai one of israel's greatest
prides in the tech ecosystem and
transitioning now to to creating a
company that that really is dealing with
one of the most difficult topics that i
think we can agree is humanity that that
are unsolved this probably some of the
most difficult for us to comprehend and
to experience and probably every person
here will understand and will connect
with with what you're doing in one way
or another and and one thing that left
me very inspired is
we chatted a while back and you
mentioned
very briefly that you know even though
you had amazing successes until now
you're this is you're seeing as your
magnum opus and you're seeing as a
legacy that you're going to leave in the
world and as a young entrepreneur i i am
inspired by the work that you do and i'm
and i'm honored that you let me be a
tiny tiny part of the nora light journey
so so michael um without further ado
tell me a little bit about how you see
yourself as an entrepreneur who are you
michael oh wow
wow
third question right let's start um
first of all thank you for all the very
kind words um who am i as an
entrepreneur i think um
i don't know how to answer that i will
say
um you know reflecting also back on what
you just said now and and you know i
don't yet know that neural light will be
my magnum opus but it is the dream that
this is what i the legacy i leave behind
and i think it's guided by
a good friend of mine gave me um
one of these um kind of business
business uh school books a while back uh
things called how to measure your life
or how you'll measure your life by
clayton christensen uh it's a it's a you
know it's it's a great book it's got a
little boring but it's uh it's a great
book
it's a in in short it's an exercise
about you know building the kpis for
your own life um and i i remember i did
this i read the book a few years back
and actually at chorus and i um
uh did the exercise and i came back with
these kpis and i'll be sharing something
i don't think it's private it usually is
it could be considered private but i
think it really is uh
it is helpful in in explaining who i am
as an entrepreneur and why i chose
a path so different and basically to
reinvent myself
in neurology
um
and helping patients and you know other
than the fact that of course and i'm
happy to share in a bit my own personal
experience with these diseases
my family experience
but um
the three quote unquote kpis of how i'll
measure my life are
the first
is
i want to leave the world a slightly
better place behind me that's you know
it's cliche these days but it's actually
in hebrew you call it
making the world a slightly better place
and once you have that as a decision or
a kpi it's very easy to decide what
you're going to be doing next with your
life and you know when friends ask like
kind of mockingly or tongue-in-cheek why
don't you go
uh and and buy yourself a small island
and retire the answer is very clear for
that the second is you know being a good
family person but also a good community
person like building a community and a
strong family around me which is really
important and something i'm very happy
to have done over the last couple of
years actually ever since doing this
exercise so i guess the book may be a
bit boring but it's effective and the
third um it's interesting enough because
it resonates exactly with the name of
what you're doing here it's to be
an inspiring leader i think you know i
did i do see things
uh around myself i i i've
i've learned a lot and i do feel i have
this ability not i'm not this you know
highly charismatic human being but i do
think i am able to inspire people by
example to do things so
um
i think as
you know i don't know how to answer who
i am as an entrepreneur i know how to
answer who i am as a human being and i'm
guided by those three kind of metrics
and i hope that gives some some kind of
color
um
beautiful i i love it and michael i
invite anybody who who wants to hear
about the first part of your career to
to go into all the incredible
announcements about about chorus ai and
the amazing things you've done there but
but here i want to focus on on
neuralight and this new journey that
you've that you've
gone on and when i think about all the
different companies that inspire me
there's only there's a handful that i
really really am inspired by it turns
out that a few of them you're actually
an angel investor and not surprisingly
but but here we're talking about a
company that's looking at neurology and
looking at at you know the 20 2022 in
neurology
nora light what is it
so wow um i'm trying to i you know
trying to think of do i do the elevator
pitch
who am i talking to so i'll just talk
like again i'll use your guidance
authentically
i'll say it this way um about 15 years
ago
actually longer
my first grandfather uh um had his wife
die
my grandmother died and i remember
writing a short story that began with
something like um
translating from hebrew uh
when my grandmother died she had to do
so again and again an innumerable number
of times
each time we had to remind myself my
grandfather again of my grandmother's
death and each time the pain would hit
him
again as if it was the first time
um and the reason i'm obviously he had
alzheimer and he didn't remember each
time we had to remind him that my
grandmother had passed um and and and
you know the pain for that was
incredible so
starting from there in this very
personal experience um so neurology
today really none of these diseases have
cures or drugs and and the reason is
there's many reasons
none of them are their lack of agents or
lack of molecules it's just extremely
extremely extremely hard
to develop drugs when you don't
understand the pathophysiologies or the
etiologies or the mechanisms but two
very similar to chorus you can't improve
what you don't measure right
rather than measuring the sales call we
we measure neurological disorders
currently today there are simply no
um
objective or sensitive endpoints for
measuring the development of the
progression of neurological disorders
which basically makes it impossible to
develop better cures better drugs
and give good care because you know how
how do you know if a drug is working or
not when say
25-30 percent of the underlying
subjects in the trial don't actually
have the disease you're measuring for
because of 30 misdiagnosis how do you um
how do you you know uh do that when
there's a 25 inner rate of variability
so what we're developing in a nutshell
is this ability to measure accurately
the progression of the of the diseases
using standard devices like a webcam
like we're using now um
uh using hard hard science not that
we've developed really important so if i
said to anybody that i was a machine
learning company my amazing co-founder
andy would jump up and say don't tell
them we're charlatans that's what he
would say um because we're
so we do also machine learning but we're
really based in deep science um and
uh we use um
uh
signal processing computer vision to be
able to discern these micro movements in
the eyes
and create a standard picture of the
neurological picture in order to to
monitor the progression of these
diseases
uh and
now rather than selling into patients
and and physicians to begin with
we're approaching uh pharma companies
we're actually
in in you know have signed the initial
phases with several of these
uh to be able to help them
uh design and build uh better studies
that have a much higher chances chances
of success i'll end in one anecdote
cns or central nervous system drugs
have
uh
only a six percent uh chance of being
approved as compared to non-cns drugs
which are more than double that rate uh
it shows you how hard it is to get a
drug approved when um
when you're not you don't know what
you're measuring
so i hope that's clear
i'm 100
um
wha why
not until now
what's been happening where where have
we been
as a society i mean we've all seen this
pain around us you're
sharing your personal experience and
thank you for sharing that all i think
all of us can relate
to somebody we know who's sort of losing
a lot of of what it means to be alive
and may be conscious through this this
disease myself personally with my own
grandfather
what
you know why haven't we been
spending so much effort into this
it's a it's a
look uh it's a great question i don't
have the full answer but i can say uh as
human beings we tend to take care of uh
the urgent not the important uh
alzheimer's ms parkinson's are not quick
killers if killers at all they're just
you know they just take 20 years to to
kill
uh
you know to to disable you um to to
come wreak havoc on your family um but
they're not like cancer that kill you in
a year or something like that so the
pain is you know is more subdued over
time neurology really important today is
is or really important to notice the
largest
uh global uh cause of disability over
one billion people in the world suffer
from some sort of neurological disorder
disease prevalence wow doubled over the
last 10 years through the aging
population so and the expenditures are
insane on alzheimer's alone direct
expenditures in the us are i think 256
billion dollars so these numbers are
insane
insane insane insane but they're slow
and the pain is more subdued and it's
you know it's not it's not tomorrow it's
over the next 20 years uh plus again we
don't yet understand the
pathophysiologies for most of these
diseases so
you know physicians are always biased
towards understanding like good
scientists right understanding what
they're actually taking care of it's
very hard to you know to to try and
solve something where you don't
understand it's like a black box the
brain is a black box right and all of
these efforts have been devoted to
oncology
uh because of it being a quicker killer
and uh
and and and also understanding things uh
i think um you know neurology is 50 60
70 years behind oncology you know
there's no precision medicine for
neurology whatsoever they're very few
disease modifying treatments there are
no cures at all available
and i think
with aging population with the fact that
we've made so much progress on oncology
with these new abilities exactly like
neurolitis is ushering in uh of actually
measuring the progression of the disease
um
and
again with aging population there's more
more
uh place and openness to doing this
um and i do believe this you know the
next decade will be uh neurology's
decade
wow incredible michael you've gotten to
to to lead an organization
very software focused um data focused
and and working with with businesses to
improve the metrics such as chorus ai
you're now leading an organization now
by it's still smaller but but i have it
no doubt that it'll get to the same
scale
with nora lights 22 people
uh we're growing quickly including by
the way the first my first engineer
uh my and good friend from chorus has
joined us um um that's if they're
probably my
the higher i'm most proud of
i don't know why
and i think that says a lot about
going back to the question of leadership
i think that that and probably that's
the test that stands the test of time
right that's the biggest validation you
can get so congratulations and thank you
but but still
i'm asking you about the day today about
the feeling about the environment about
the progression about the atmosphere the
culture
is there a difference when you're
working on a product such as what
choruses and versus what nora light is
yes yes so first it's much easier to
hire um
we all of our engineers are you know
i know your dad is involved in google so
sorry but we poached quite a bit of
people from google um and and microsoft
and uh and as i said corey so all the
people are
you know it's it's much easier to hire
people are are coming not all he doesn't
help with it i just have to say for the
record he didn't know that he doesn't
help okay
we'd appreciate i'm joking um
uh
look um it's easier to hire uh also you
know having built a few companies what
we did this time was we before we went
before we started the path uh we we set
three values for the company to
you know to put together the anchors
culturally of the and the dna and we
spent you know days actually distilling
um
this into three values the reason we did
three is because both eddie and i
uh have a memory of birds and we
wouldn't ever remember three and we
actually want these three valves to be
used in real life so we we every single
interview
uh candidate decision we fall back to
our values the values are very very
simple the first is we're on an urgent
mission um so we're looking for people
that are dedicated and passionate about
actually changing the world for the
better
when we interviewed
eddie and i still interview every single
person both of us every single person
joining the company i take the usually
the last interview and i share the
values and i say look this means that we
don't like the phrase work life balance
and i want to see the reaction and the
truth is not because and you'll see us
in the second the the last value it's
the reason is we're actually not looking
for people that want this balance but
rather the people that think that the
this job will be a significant part of
their life not there's no balance
between job and life because we want you
to feel that this job is an important
and meaningful part of your life um so
you know work life harmony is
is fine uh and
i think a much better um kind of phrase
but really really important for us is i
want to see if people are scared of that
or not because if they are they're
probably not the right person not
because we work crazy hours although
sometimes we do
anecdotally we discovered a few weeks
ago that um a team of our engineers were
working the entire weekend and eddie and
i were horrified because we had not
asked for that um and we thought that
maybe we'd conveyed some state of
urgency that wasn't the case whatever so
we we reached out and said no no we
really wanted to start the trials
you know early next week and it was too
important for us obviously we we we kind
of told them look thank you and we gave
them a few weeks later we organized like
a uh
uh yom kefa uh whatever an external
happy day whatever for them uh but but
more importantly what was you know
really important for us that we have
people that make this an integral part
of their life um the third value by the
way skipping the second is uh we enjoy
the ride right so it's kind of making
sure that we have the balance right this
is it you know if we don't enjoy the
ride i don't know you know the the path
is just as important as the goal
the second value
is psychological safety um you know
going back to google actually there's an
amazing project that google ran reported
in the new york times about the
importance of psychological safety and
how
absolutely critical like google did this
amazing research and founded that most
the top
top top performing teams are ones where
people feel vulnerable enough to to know
that they'll never be dismissed that
they'll always be empowered etc so
uh that's a critical second value for us
um and i think those values actually
reflect who we are as a company how we
make decisions
um we are definitely as entrepreneurs
and um
by the way recently we had gilsh klarsky
uh the cto previous cto of flatiron
joined as a scientific co-founder and i
wrote him in a personal note he hasn't
yet received this hopefully this is
published after we together with his
swag we've been working with him you
know week and week off for the last year
plus when i wrote there are very few
people if you know i didn't think there
were any people that could join eddie
and me as the founding team and make us
better more resilient more robust
whatever and you proved me wrong but
that you know one of the reasons i said
that is
so gil not only is absolutely incredibly
brilliant iq eq whatever but i visited
him in new york with my
my life partner and our baby daughter uh
about half a year ago and what most
impressed me was not his iq was not how
how amazingly well he understood the
space etc etc but the fact that he
didn't care about me at all all he cared
about was making sure that veronica and
ellie were were taking care of my my my
life partner and my daughter uh the
amount of empathy the amount of end so
that was like absolutely huge so going
back to your question is there a
difference yes we're extremely
intentional about our culture uh we are
looking to hire and bring in people that
deeply care about this
um that are motivated by by the goal uh
and have the wherewithal to be
vulnerable which is demands a lot of
courage um and would never ever be
negative and or dismissive in any way uh
and also
enjoy enjoy the ride i'll end with a
quick anecdote um
eddie and i often uh interview these
amazing human beings that are extremely
brilliant like 180 iq whatever
um
but they may not be a great cultural fit
maybe they're they're you know unhappy
people or bitter or whatever so eddie
and i are sometimes very tempted to hire
them nonetheless but we go back to the
values so the joke is between eddie and
me that sometimes we we should we should
build this um this daughter company uh
called uh grimaces uh nah like
and never tell them that there's a real
company called newer lighted like two
years later they'll come oh you actually
have a real-life office whatever
something like that but we obviously
misha um
these are the types of conversations
that that i leave smiling and inspired
and uh
and and thankful that that these types
of things exist and um on a personal
level uh thank you for for working on
progressing with it with a problem that
very few people have the the the drive
and the understanding and the ambition
to to go and help solve and
and i have no doubt that the team that
that i'm seeing in front of me is the
team that is positioned to do that and
and so thank you for all the the great
work thank you for the 20 minutes that
you're spending here with me i know how
busy you are i know that i know that you
had to that you were up until 3 a.m last
night and i had and i still woke you up
early so thank you for agreeing to that
nevertheless i wish it was 3am but thank
you michael it's it's um it's been a
real real real pleasure uh again i love
what you're doing i've been following
this for a while um i'm very very
grateful that you're part of our journey
um and thank you for giving me the stage
it's actually an amazing way to start my
day it's i actually you've helped me
you've helped remind me of why i'm doing
what i'm doing
uh and thank you for the thoughtful
questions and uh
uh for giving me this stage i really
really appreciate it
thank you
[Music]